there's some crazy stuff happening down
in texas when it comes to bitcoin mining
as we all know texas is one of the
largest oil and gas locations in the
united states and all of a sudden that
industry is turning onto bitcoin mining
as the single greatest way for them to
monetize all that energy now down in
fort worth what we're seeing is the city
council is voting this week on accepting
a donation of three bitcoin miners they
would sit inside of their government
facility and actually mine bitcoin this
is a huge attempt for them to become
more crypto friendly or bitcoin friendly
now as you start to think about why
would a local government go ahead and do
this one they're getting educated
they're realizing that bitcoin can be
the solution for a lot of problems and
create economic prosperity great jobs
and it can ultimately help them
stabilize their grid as they think about
accepting these what they're really
doing is they're putting on display
their thought process about bitcoin and
the crypto industry as we see the city
council vote for this it'll be real
interesting because if the city council
starts to mine bitcoin and literally
profit off of this donation they're
gonna hold bitcoin on their balance
sheet and i guess that a lot of other
cities states and local economies all of
a sudden they're gonna have people
showing up saying hey i'd like to just
gift you this one bitcoin miner two
bitcoin miners three bitcoin miners
really people just wanna get bitcoin in
the hands of their politicians and their
local governments because it changes the
way they think about the industry now
this is obviously a really big deal
because over the last six to 12 months
what we've seen is hash rate from around
the world it's moved into the united
states now the u.s accounts for almost
50 percent of total hash rate after
china went ahead and banned bitcoin
mining in 2021 as we continue to see
this occur what we are going to watch is
the united states is going to get more
and more concentrated ownership of that
hash rate that means that bitcoin miners
around the world are gonna have to step
up and start to balance it back out so
even the united states doesn't own more
than 51 percent if we go back to texas
though for a second we've got the ceo of
poland kevin sitting here saying texas
will be the bitcoin capital of the world
in the next two years whether you agree
with them or you don't what we know is
that texas is going to take a real run
at it they already have about 10 of the
global hash rate and they're only going
to continue to lean in to their dna
which is the oil and gas energy and all
that energy production then if we take a
look here we've got a quote from colin
harper over at luxor technologies he
says texas is an energy state and it has
too much to gain many politicians in
texas are starting to see the benefits
bitcoin mining can bring be those from
tax revenue job creation or grid
stabilizing at the end of the day
bitcoin miners are gonna flow to where
they can find cheap energy and somewhere
like texas has tons and tons of excess
cheap energy and so naturally i do agree
that texas will become the capital of
bitcoin mining around the world that's
great for texas that's great for the us
and it's ultimately great for bitcoin as
we continue to see this play out wait
and watch as many local governments
start to adopt bitcoin in various ways
maybe they'll accept it maybe they'll
pay some of their employees in it maybe
they'll go ahead and actually mine
bitcoin themselves however they do it
politicians at the local and state level
are realizing bitcoin's good for
business and they're trying to get in
the game hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time